-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
I'm hanging out
with my good friend.
I'm hanging out with my son,
Post Malone.
Post.
-What's up, Dad?
-Since you are about
to launch your brand-new
Celebrity World Pong League,
I wanted to challenge you
to the Every Drinking Game Ever
Challenge.
♪ -Every drinking game
challenge ♪
-Okay.
Post, this first one
is a classic.
The first game we're about
to play is Flip Cup.
-Flip Cup. First one to drink
and flip all their cups wins.
-Are you nervous at all?
-Not at all.
-Ready?
-Yes, sir.
-Set. Go!
♪♪
-Oh, my God.
[ Dinging ]
-Oh! What's up, dude?!
Yo! What is up, dude?!
What is up, man?! Blah!
[ Laughs ]
-Quarters.
Bounce the quarter off the table
into the glass.
-I'm going to be
straight with you.
I've never played this game.
It seems a bit primordial.
-Alright, ready? Here we go.
On your mark. Get set. Go.
♪♪
-Oh, no.
-God. That one went backward.
Oh, my gosh!
Yo!
[ Dinging ]
Oh, my gosh!
Dude, what is happening?
Grandpa's got to get
back out on the scene!
You missed the --
This is like old timer's day
at the ballpark.
I come limping out.
Can we have a replay of that,
Dave,
just so Post can see
the magic of this?
Watch this. Watch this gem.
Boing!
-Oh, my God.
-Doing!
[ Laughs ]
Ah!
Enjoy that cold beverage,
my friend.
Cheers.
-Cheers, Jim.
-Cheers, bud.
-Never Have I Ever.
Put a finger down
if you've done the deed.
First person with all fingers
down loses.
-Three fingers up. I will start.
Never have I ever, uh,
lost $1,000 on a bet.
-Specifically $1,000?
-In that ballpark.
-Or over?
-Over?
-Yeah, I've made some dumb bets
in my life.
So are you saying over $1,000?
-Yeah, I'm going to say $10,000.
-Okay, let's do $10,000, too.
Okay.
-You got to put a finger down,
oh, my gosh.
Okay. Alright, now you ask.
-Never have I ever...
taken the postal exam
as a career fallback.
-[ Laughs ]
You sadly know
too much about me.
My parents really believed in
my comedy career and I was a --
I would have been
a great mailman.
And I got job offers.
And they would have loved me.
But, yes, I have done that.
And gosh, I love the post office
and I love postal workers.
Okay, my man, have you ever --
never have I ever gone out
for drinking one night and then
woke up in a different city.
Actually, you know what?
That's bad for me
because I have done that.
-Yeah, I'll drink too.
Cheers, sir.
[ Laughter ]
-Two times.
You got one for me?
-Never have I ever been mistaken
for another celebrity.
-Oh, my gosh.
That happens to me all the time.
Tom Cruise. Every time I go out.
-Tom Cruise?
-Yeah, absolutely, yeah.
Tom Cruise, yeah, all the time.
-I'll put mine down too 'cause
I get Brad Pitt all the time.
-Beer Pong.
Throw a Ping-Pong ball
in your opponent's cups.
First to sink each cup wins.
-Post, since you're the resident
beer pong expert,
I'm going to go first.
Here we go.
Hey, do you soak your ball?
Do you get it wet
before you throw?
-Yes, sir.
You know, it's impoi--
it's "impoitant" to make it --
[ Laughs ]
It's impoitant to make it --
-Of "coirse."
Of coirse it's impoitant.
Here we go, bud.
♪♪
Oh, gosh.
-That's alright. That's alright.
-Come on, bud.
Let's see what you got.
♪♪
-Ooh!
-Aah!
Gosh darn. Which one?
Top one you did?
I know this is going to be bad.
♪♪
Gosh. Ugh!
Alright, come on, come on.
Let's make it close.
Uh! God.
That was just ugly, ugly!
That was just ugly!
♪♪
-Oh!
-Oh, my God.
-He's a master. Dude,
he's a ninja. He's a master.
-I got to be honest. On the pong
show, I didn't do so well.
It was not my week.
-Two down. Alright.
Here we go. Gosh.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
I think I just hit you
in the -- hit you in the nad.
-Oh!
-Oh, my gosh!
[ Dinging ]
He's the master.
He is the master!
He remains the champion!
Post Malone, everybody!
His new show, "Post Malone's
Celebrity World Pong League,"
is out November 18th on
Messenger's Watch Together.
You're the champ, Posty.
Always good to see you, pal.
Stick around.
We got more "Tonight Show."
♪♪